Ahí estaba esa mujer que sabía todo sobre mí
y yo no sabía nada de ella.
Ni siquiera recuerdo haber dicho adiós.
PSW: Ese día solo era capaz de pensar
que era finales de septiembre en Nueva York
y yo llevaba pantalones blancos.
(Risas)
No se lleva blanco después del Día del Trabajo en Nueva York.
Llamaron a la puerta
y en lo único que pensaba era que aquí estoy con los pantalones equivocados.
Y entonces vi esos enormes ojos azules que tanto adoro
que me miraban con incredulidad.
Y pensé: "Oh, esto no va a ser fácil".
Cuando alguien de la familia hace la transición,
también lo hace toda la familia, ya sea que lo quieran o no.
Para los que lo ven desde fuera es fácil.
Los liberales decían: "¡Oh, estupendo!
Ella ha encontrado su verdad, es maravilloso".
Y los conservadores decían: "Eso está fatal, me largo".
(Risas)
Pero para mi familia, ningún extremo iba a funcionar.
Su enfado, su dolor,
su amor y su lealtad...
todo tenía que pasar por el camino de las pruebas.
JW: ¿Había sido todo mentira?
Cada vez que jugábamos en el jardín, las entradas de los Mets...
¿habían pasado con mi padre o con ella?
Recuerdo una vez
que mi padre me llevó a montar en bici por el parque Hecksche
para hablarme sobre sexo.
Me explicó las partes del cuerpo que ahora sé que él deseaba que no fueran suyas.
¿Había llegado a existir mi padre?
El dolor...
el dolor no tiene normas.
El dolor toma prestado tu auto sin permiso,
lo destroza
y luego no se disculpa.
Y yo estaba destrozado.
Esto era duro.
Me refugié en mí mismo.
Estaba enfadado.
Me sentía traicionado.
Debería haber sabido
por el hecho de que me animabas a seguir a los Mets
que me preparabas para las grandes decepciones de la vida.
(Risas)
Es verdad.
Y aún así estaban los juegos en el jardín,
las entradas de temporada
y los sándwhiches de tocino, huevo y queso de los sábados
del mejor sitio de bagels de Long Island.
Mi padre vivió una vida que no quería vivir,
pero lo hizo para que yo pudiera tener un padre.
Dejé de preguntarme si mi padre había existido.
Había existido, de manera obstinada, consciente e intencional,
todos los días de mi infancia.
Le estaba agradecido por eso.
El cuerpo de Paula ahora era suyo y su transformación estaba completa,
pero la mía estaba empezando.
Tenía otra prueba, otro viaje, otra elección para seguir el consejo
de continuar por el camino estrecho.
PSW: La mayoría de los días creo que hay un Dios.
Los martes y los jueves pueden ser duros
y cualquier día que pasen por el New Jersey Turnpike.
Ya saben, ¿no?
(Risas)
Es difícil creer en Dios cuando tu alma está en el cuerpo equivocado.
Aún así, de alguna manera acabé en el clero.
Cuando perdí todos mis trabajos no fue nada personal.
Es lo que hacen las tribus religiosas.
Creen que hace falta un enemigo para que sobreviva la tribu,
así que si no hay enemigo,
lo crean.
Ahora mismo el enemigo son las minorías sexuales;
mi salida fue rápida y segura.
Me sorprendí cuando mi hijo dejó su trabajo de profesor en Filadelfia oeste
para meterse en el clero.
No me lo esperaba.
Y entonces me pregunté:
¿qué haría él?
No tuve que esperar tanto tiempo para encontrar una respuesta.
Seis meses después de esa primera visita
me invitó otra vez a Nueva York.
JW: Los diseñadores del puente de Brooklyn
tuvieron su dosis de mala suerte.
John Roebling murió poco después de que comenzara la construcción del puente.
Su hijo Washington tomó el relevo
pero tuvo síndrome de descompresión.
Su mujer, Emily, pasó a ser la ingeniera ejecutiva sustituta
y supervisó la finalización del puente.
Padre e hijo,
John y Washington,
vencidos por su trabajo.
Un día soleado de mayo
mi padre y yo estábamos sentados a la sombra de dicho puente.
¿Serían nuestras vidas como las de los Roebling...
padre e hijo vencidos por nuestro trabajo?
Mi padre pensaba que sus amigos de la iglesia
le acompañarían durante su transición,
pero no lo hicieron.
La abandonaron y se aferraron a mí.
Yo era pastor en una nueva iglesia de Brooklyn.
Era un grupo maravilloso de gente progresista
y aún así estábamos económicamente atados a iglesias muy conservadoras.
Hacer sitio a Paula significaba poner en peligro el sustento de nuestra iglesia.
Yo estaba en la línea entre estos dos mundos enfrentados.
Así que le dije a mi padre,
"Papá, yo todavía vivo y trabajo en tu antiguo mundo.
¿Cabe la posibilidad de que hagas una ofrenda de paz por mí?".
Y su respuesta fue apasionada.
Me dijiste: "¿Tienes idea de lo que se siente
cuando por fin uno se muestra a sus verdaderos amigos
y ellos te rechazan de lleno?
¿Que te pidan vivir una mentira?
¿Sabes qué se siente?".
Y yo no sabía qué se sentía.
Pero sabía que tenía que tomar una decisión.
Era la decisión de continuar por ese camino estrecho por las noches,
pero por pimera vez
vi un destello de luz.
No puedo pedir a mi padre que sea otra cosa que no fuera su verdadero yo.
(Aplausos)
PSW: Ese día, sentados a la orilla del río,
Jonathan habló de su dolor, su sufrimiento, su confusión.
En esa conversación puso todo sobre la mesa
y me destrozó
ser la causa de ese dolor.
Pero mientras hablaba había algo de redención,
llena de tensión pero de posibilidad,
anclado en el camino estrecho.
Él dijo: "Esto siempre va a ser duro.
Siempre lo será.
Pero papá,
te quiero".
Mi hijo es lo mejor de mí y más.
Es valiente y fuerte,
sensible y considerado.
Supongo que se podría decir
que es un macho alfa delicado.
JW: Era hora de que mis hijas conocieran a su... Paula.
Volvimos a mi apartamento,
mis hijas estaban coloreando sobre la mesa del comedor
y se produjo un silencio incómodo.
Y de repente, la más pequeña hizo una sola pregunta con mucha seguridad.
"Abuelo, ¿tienes pene?".
(Risas)
Y cuando se redujeron la tensión y las risas,
mis hijas se llevaron a su abuelo a su habitación,
le enseñaron sus juguetes nuevos
y le bautizaron con un nombre nuevo.
La llamaron "PaulAbuela".
(Risas)
PSW: El verano pasado tuve a mis cinco nietas en casa,
en las laderas de las Montañas Rocosas.
Fuimos a nadar en las aguas más frías del río
que corre por nuestro pueblecito.
Y un día, una de las hijas de Jonathan me dijo:
"PaulAbuela, ¿podemos hacer tubing en el río?".
Y les dije: "Bueno...
yo esperaría hasta que su padre llegara.
Creo que él es quien debería decidirlo".
Y ella dijo: "Pero PaulAbuela,
él tomaría exactamente la misma decisión que tú.
Se parece mucho a ti, sabes".
(Risas)
Y yo pensé, sí, se parece mucho a mí,
los dos estamos empeñados en encontrar el camino estrecho
y en seguirlo a través de la larga y oscura noche
hasta el amanecer.
JW: ¿Alguna vez han notado que un niño que tiene seguridad,
que conoce el amor,
es un niño que bailará?
Mueven sus brazos,
mueven las piernas al ritmo de una música que solo oyen ellos.
Es la música de un niño que está seguro e ileso
y es tremendamente querido.
El día después de que mis hijas conocieran a PaulAbuela,
ella les llevó a comprar donuts,
yo las miraba mientras ellas caminaban
y mis hijas tomaron los brazos de mi padre
y bailaron.
Los brazos de mi padre se movían a lo loco.
Les compraste demasiados donuts porque siempre lo haces...
(Risas)
Vi a mi hija mayor tomar un bocado del donut
y nos deleitó con dos saltos y un giro.
Fue perfecto.
Ese camino estrecho
tiene siempre sus cargas y sus retos.
Pero estaba seguro de que persistiríamos hasta la redención.
Miré a mi padre
y miré a mis hijas que estaban bailando y comiendo sus donuts
y dije en alto a nadie en concreto,
dije: "Así...
así es como Dios ve a mi padre".
Mi padre volvió a nacer, literalmente.
Y al elegir el camino estrecho de la redención
yo volví a nacer con ella.
Gracias.
(Aplausos y ovación)